my guest tonight is a grammy
award-winning rapper and
actor who has appeared in seven fast and
furious films
now he has a new media platform for kids
called kid nation and it's a fantastic
idea
uh this guy's doing great work please
welcome chris ludacris
bridges how you doing chris what's going
on my man how you feeling i'm feeling
okay i'm getting by i'm ready for all
this to be over
i'm ready to get out there uh have fun i
know you've been hanging out
is it is your place outside atlanta is
that where it is
no i mean it's south side of atlanta so
you just wanted the suburbs college park
where i grew up when you school so yeah
you can say that
now now tell me about this you're
hanging out on a pretty substantial
property i don't want
i know you don't want to brag but i'll
brag on your behalf you've got like
22 acres is that right yes i do man and
i mean if i was going to be quarantined
anywhere this would definitely be the
place to be so 22 acres of land
i'm able to i don't know if you know
this or not but i have all women in my
household so i have three daughters
all right no sons i have a wife
uh her mother comes and visits my mother
comes to visit
the only other pair of balls in this
household is the dog and me and him walk
outside every 15 minutes to get away
from all of this estrogen that's in this
household
22 acres of land is great
i got two things to say first i'm
impressed that your dog still has his
balls
because that was the first thing to go
um they took mine when they took my dogs
uh and then the other thing is i gotta
say you got 22 acres
it's perfect like if there was a zombie
apocalypse
i would say get me to chris ludacris
bridge's house i want to hang out there
you've got a secure perimeter
right this is the perfect place to be
absolutely and a dog who will do
anything for me because he wants to get
out of this house full of women just as
much as i do
yeah so yes if anyone comes anywhere
close he's adam
believe that i can't take his balls away
because we're the only two with a pair
of balls come on man
i don't want to be the only pair of
balls yeah so so wait a minute so
you've got all these women in the house
do you handle that well do you like
being the only guy or do you really wish
the dog aside there was another guy
hanging around and are
and are you inviting me over is that's
what's happening you are 100
invited over and to answer your original
question you know to be honest
it's more of an investment because when
you have all these women
you know later on in life they're going
to take care of you you know what i'm
saying if you have sons what i've heard
is
they don't really give a damn when you
get older but when you have daughters
you get older and they take care of you
so it's an investment so it's something
to look forward to this is what i tell
my kids all the time
sometime in the next five years you're
gonna have to start carrying me to the
toilet
that's and not because i'm in firm just
because i'm too late i'm just gonna go
limp and you gotta
that's your job i've done a lot once i
pay for college you're carrying me to
the toilet that's what's happening
listen i hope you got some strong kids
because you are one tall
pay but mother can tell you it's gonna
be they're gonna have to carry
a lot of them carrying you god damn it
man yeah i know i gotta it's gonna be
take a lot of people uh now
i understand you've got a tennis court
that you weren't using before on your
property
but now here's the thing i've noticed
about this pandemic we're all starting
to do things we weren't doing before
you started using your tennis court
right bro listen this tennis court and
you can look on my social media if you
want to
the tennis court was just on my property
for like over 10 years just
writing i even had a lyric in a song
where i said my 10th
my tennis court is rotten and i'm
waiting on serena like waiting on
cerulean
serena williams in order to play so now
i just redid the whole court because
i was bored as hell at home and now i
started playing on it so
i'm loving playing tennis and learning
to the game and uh
i feel like in about a couple weeks or
so i'll be ready for the masters uh
wimbledon whatever you guys want to
throw at right okay
yeah so you're also good at golf because
masters is golf sorry i had to say that
yeah
i had to say that no what i meant to say
was i'm a master
yes i'll be ready for any of the masters
there you go
consider themselves as masters in the
tennis game
that's a very good save which means you
are ready you have all the requisite
skills uh
what about your house i imagine this is
a big house are you
are you using every room in your house
are you finding
like you're using spaces like during
this quarantine i started using my
dining room i wasn't using my dining
room a lot and we would use it
but it was always just for company and
now i try and go in there just because
it's a different space
i'm i'm finding new uses for things let
me let you in on a little secret uh
conan i used every room in this house
before i was married but
i don't want to get in trouble okay so
i'm just gonna i'm gonna leave that
alone yes i i have used every room in
this house that wait
okay let me just i don't want to get you
in trouble but when you were a single
man
you used every room in the house oh for
sure
and now that i'm a married man i'm still
using every room in the house
very nice i've even added on rooms in
order to
you know make sure that that we use more
rooms that weren't here before
the whole point
so okay so even before you were using
the tennis court for tennis
you were using the tennis court i was
using the tennis court for
golf because i wanted to go to the
master yeah
i was just hitting a random golf ball on
a rotting tennis court
and it was so rotten it would look like
grass that's what i'm trying to tell i
love it
i love it it all comes together very
nice uh now i know you opened a
restaurant that's doing real well tell
me about this restaurant what's it
called
the restaurant is called chicken and
beer man it's named after my third album
that went triple platinum humbly
speaking but to bring it from
an idea an inception of just an album
name and then make it into a restaurant
which is in the busiest airport in the
world
atlanta hartsfield jackson airport
concourse b is amazing so chicken and
beer do you like chicken
yeah who doesn't like chicken i love
chicken do you like beer i love beer
okay well there you have it man you
gotta come to chicago now
uh well i had a restaurant for about a
year just called the potato
and all you could get was a potato that
was it i'm not believing this right now
i was trying to get it i was trying to
get in touch with my irish heritage and
it was just
you could get a potato and you couldn't
get it different ways it was just a
baked potato that was
it you know i don't i'm not offended
because a lot of people used to say that
i look
like mr potato head but because that's
why i got this
afro i really started getting away from
that but yes man i can respect the
potato
and and uh all of its vitamins and
minerals that it has
yeah well that restaurant folded very
quickly
uh now i want to talk to you for a
second about the fast and furious films
you've been in so many of these films
and
um i this is a true story uh absolutely
true
two days ago i watched fast and furious
seven
uh with a friend of mine uh my head
writer matt we watched it again
because that the stunts are just so
insane and i just keep thinking i don't
know how they
top this because every time i watch the
movie i mean in the last movie
you guys were driving cars from one
tower into another tower into another
tower
you were jumping out of airplanes in
cars
uh it gets to the point where i think
what what can you do
that hasn't been done already with these
cars
listen i can't give it away but conan i
can promise you
that we are doing something that has
never been done
so june 25th is the final date because
of course we got pushed back
sure because of covid and theaters not
being open right but on june 25th
everyone will have their shot at going
to see yet another like
extremely ridiculous ludicrous
fast and furious movie yeah part of the
theater experience yeah i
i i go i know stencil uh and i swear to
god i love that everything has to
involve a car
like if you guys have to break into a
closet you've got to drive into the
closet
in a car you everything has to happen in
a car
if you have to pretend to be waiters to
get the bad guys
you dress up as waiters and you drive
into the front of the window of the
restaurant in a car
i love it facts man you know what's even
crazier
a lot of people don't know this but
every single fast and furious i bought
one of the cars that was in the movie
i've heard this i've heard this
except for the ones where we shot in
london where the steering wheel
was on the other side of the car
because i didn't want to deal with that
yeah all of the other ones i bought cars
as a matter of fact there was one from
too fast too furious
if we have real fast and furious fans on
here there was a
dodge truck that had like a louis
vuitton wrap on it
i have it i have it right here this
is the car and it's a truck
dodge truck wrapped with louis
vuitton insignias on it
and you bought this car and you drove it
around
how did that go how was the experience
of driving this car around
it didn't go well at all i drove it for
one day
and everyone in the city of atlanta
georgia knew it was me
i had a tailgating party like everyone
was behind me
and has literally never wanted to drive
this car ever again so i gave it away to
my friend at the time so that he
could have people follow him all the
damn time right now all i drive is
my 93 acura legend because this is the
exact opposite
of having a louis vuitton wrapped uh
truck
okay so you drive a 93 acura
legend you man ludacris drives around in
a 93
acura legend so this is a car that i had
before
i was commercially successful as a
rapper one of my favorite cars has over
250 000
miles on it still drive it to this day
that's the it's the car that i drive the
most you know what i had i had before i
got
on television i had a 92 ford
taurus what not don't give me attitude
that's the hell did you fit in that car
like you're too tall no no
i caught you i cut a hole i cut a hole
in the roof
you know and uh but i would drive around
this car
ladies love a 92 ford taurus
okay this thing was a magnet all right
they didn't even care who was driving
they were like whoever's in that ford
taurus
i've got to be with that man and the
same way i said i took advantage of
every room in my house you took
advantage of every seat in the four
tours is what you're trying to tell yes
exactly
exactly yeah i mean this was and i could
it was insanity
and i kept that car i still have that
car to this day
because it brings back so many wild
memories
but one day me and you have to drive our
acura legend and four taurus around the
town
just to do it okay let's do it this is
what i want to do
i want us to do that but first i want
your acura
and my tourists to be wrapped in the
louis vuitton logo
then we drive them around now i got to
ask you about this
you uh got a car
that bounces and we have actually some
footage of you
bouncing in this car let's show the
footage and then i want you to explain
why let's take a look
that's not me doing that baby that's the
car doing that
okay why do you need a car
it does that what is it what does it do
for you
listen man this is a very good reason
like most of the time we listen to music
we're in the car right right right you
need a car
to dance with you when you dance
now you're laughing but this is true man
who the hell wants a car
if you're dancing in the car stand still
yeah come on conan
that's right that makes no sense
whatsoever you're right your car needs
to be able to dance with you
i can see that yeah think about your
ford taurus if it was able to bounce the
same way
that that uh mercedes maybach did yeah
it had been a whole different situation
and your car would have been doing most
of the work with the women that you were
with in the four tours you wouldn't have
had to do much
guess what i'm told i didn't do much oh
i get a lot of complaints
back in the day a lot of complaints i
tend to lay perfectly still
um
the car was the only thing that moved i
look i'm very shy
and i don't like to move um
that's uh by the way what did you think
of my dancing chris
yeah you're a blatantly honest guy so
i'm sure you wouldn't mind me being
blatantly honest back to you
your dancing is terrible what are you
talking about i'm exploring the space
around
no no you need a car that bounces man
immediately
if you ever go to wimbledon or the
masters make sure you don't dance in the
stands i know
i will i will i will i'll be you're
right this is good
you know what you've been a good friend
of me over the years and you being
honest with me i really appreciate it
because i think a lot of people would
have said conan you're the best dancer
i've ever seen
you cut right to the chase and you saved
me you kept me humble and i thank you
no for sure 100 sometimes certain things
just aren't for us man you need to
concentrate on other things
yeah okay please tell me what that is
because i've never figured it out
let's talk about this let's talk about
uh kid nation
uh because this is a really good idea
and um i think this deserves to be
discussed on the show
because this is something you came up
with and i really love it once you
explain what kid nation is to people who
don't know
absolutely man it's a platform that i
just launched of course it's for
children it's enriching content so you
have all this music
talking about science talking about math
talking about eating vegetables drinking
water
and it's all a safe place for kids and
parents to go to especially at a time
where there's a lot of virtual schooling
yeah we need supplemental edutainment as
i like to call it so
it is a platform and it's an app so
kidnation.com
um i mean when you see it it's going to
100
do way better than explaining than i can
it's it's so enriching and it's so great
for the times right now it's just me
trying to balance out
all that adult entertainment that i've
been making for the last 20 years
yeah yeah i think first of all i think
it's a great idea and when i was growing
up there was something called
schoolhouse rock
and it was really good music that
actually
i think my concept or my original
knowledge of how a bill gets passed came
from schoolhouse rock
i learned so much uh from that and i've
been thinking lately like oh someone
needs to take this to the next level and
make music that's relevant today so the
fact that you're doing
just that is perfect exactly what it is
that's exactly what kid nation is and
i'm glad that you understand it
so greatly appreciate you on that man
i'm just trying to balance out the world
there's a lot of negativity there's a
lot of craziness going on
it's always good to be the change you
want to see and put some good back into
the universe or the ludaverse
as i like to call it oh wow okay all
right or
the conivers as i like no no no no no no
no no no
that's not that doesn't work okay yeah
put that in the same bag with the
dancing
you know what you i you're always honest
with me and again i appreciate it so
i want to ensure i get the word out
check out kid nation at
www.kidnation.com
for a free one month subscription
and this sounds uh like a very
very uh valuable tool this is something
kids need right now my kids need this
right now so
thank you for doing it appreciate it
thank you for having me man greatly
appreciate it
and you know i'll always be uh coming up
with more exciting things so we'll talk
again soon all right well i'm coming to
your house
uh we're gonna hang um i gotta get my
car
i gotta get my tourists fixed and i'm
going to make it out there because you
need some more
who's got more male energy and
masculinity than this guy
i will come to your house and i'll help
you all right sounds like a plan man me
and my dog will be waiting
okay uh hey take it easy chris you'd be
good ludacris
everybody yes appreciate you man